today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you read or listen to
an entire nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
below this video
welcome everybody um i've been
mentioning that
this segment has to be done and the
reason this segment has to be done is
there are some real problems
for the democratic party to solve in the
next two years and certainly beyond that
because joe biden
won uh but he barely won in a sense
whether joe biden ends up with 290 or
306
in the end in the electoral college the
reality is that he will have won
by a couple hundred thousand votes in
three to four states
and it's fantastic news that joe biden
won and as i said
during the live stream on saturday
during president-elect biden's speech
that this is something to celebrate this
is something to rejoice about and yet
at the same time as of right now and the
votes are still being counted
more than 71 million people voted for
donald trump
71 million people saw the last four
years
knew they had an alternative and said
give me another four years of donald
trump
millions of people who didn't vote for
trump in 2016
said even though i didn't vote for him
after four years of insanity
i now am going to go out and vote for
donald trump
that's a disaster early 2020 exit polls
also suggest joe biden did much worse
with hispanic voters in some key states
than hillary clinton did in 2016
in some cases by significant margins
we're still waiting on
final data you have this massive
recession
impossibly bad unimaginably bad handling
of coronavirus some of the worst in the
world
and democrats can maybe tie in the
senate we have to see what happens with
the georgia runoffs
barely win the presidency and lose seats
in the house of representatives
now there are two sides to this and we
have to be able to hold both sides there
will be people who look at me
talking about this and will say david
but trumpists are idiots listen
there's two sides okay on the one side
there are many trumpists that are
ignorant
there are many trumpets that have been
bamboozled and weaponized into oblivion
there's no question that a huge part of
this is unempathetic people
uh ignorant people hyper partisan people
super religious people who have fallen
for trump's supposed religiosity even
though biden's actually the religious
candidate
but we can't only focus on them because
there's also a lot of problems on this
on the left and within the democratic
party
if the starting point is let's find dumb
people and point and laugh
and just attack trumpists as dumb uh
okay i mean listen that can be a
starting point and there's plenty of
them
but if the goal is how can we avoid what
was almost
another disaster and how can we actually
get policy successes in the future
we have to look at what's happening on
the left as well there's no way around
it it would be
responsible not to and in fact we have
to take some responsibility because
understand that this election almost was
democrats lose some of their advantage
in the house
don't get the senate and trump gets
reelected instead
we have democrats lose some seats in the
house
win the white house with an unclear
senate as of right now
and razor thin margins in a ton of races
it's pathetic to lose house seats
not win the senate and barely win the
white house when this president has done
everything wrong
and the united states has become a
complete and total laughing stock
around the world it's a disaster and the
first thing that we have to understand
is something i've been saying for years
which is that donald trump didn't create
the people we now call trumpists
they've been around for a long time
they've mostly defaulted to the
republican party
they've been brainwashed by right-wing
media they've been lied to
by the republican party talk radio has
been right-wing
for decades and has been preaching to
them racism and xenophobia and
anti-science
anti-intellectualism it's all been
around for decades what donald trump did
was provide an avenue for them
to be more comfortable expressing their
views in public
and has coalesced them but step one
is trump didn't create these people and
they don't go away when donald trump
leaves
secondly we have to recognize that the
71 million people that voted for donald
trump
aren't all racist or xenophobic or
anti-science or religious nuts
many of them are one of those things a
bunch of them are all of those things
but there are also tons of people
tens of millions of people who vote
republican as a result of culture
they of the culture they grew up in uh
because that's what their family does
because they don't really pay that much
attention to politics but they just kind
of default to
we don't vote for democrats sometimes
it's because of actual false beliefs
about democrats but
71 million people is a huge number and
there's
no one thing that applies to all of them
other than
the democratic party has to do something
about at least some of them if the
democratic party wants a shot
in the future and in total there is a
huge
cult-like element to the american right
as was posted to our subreddit
there is no what i would call retail
strategy to deprogram people at that
scale when you're talking about 71
million people
particularly because the deprogramming
that would need to be done is different
for a lot of these different groups it's
not all the same for 71 million people
so there should be some wholesale
strategy now
some of you will email me and say david
these people are deplorable like hillary
said why are you defending trumpists
wrong question i am not defending
trumpists
i care about winning by winning winning
winning
by moving the country to the left
lifting the standard of living
lifting the quality of healthcare and
education having a country that isn't
laughed at all over the world
it's just a mathematical reality we need
some of these people to have a shot at
real progress okay we can't just
skate by with razor thin margins
while the other side also has record
numbers of votes
so while it's fun for now you know
there's this brief period
where i get it right like we laugh we
say you guys lost they're so triggered
it's funny we got biden they can't even
admit it your deal leader leader trump
is going
bye-bye i i get it like i'm part i think
it's it's cathartic
and i think it's it's uh um satisfying
to some degree
at some point the democratic party has
to account for
why they continue to barely be able to
win
despite the right putting up cartoonish
lunatics as leaders and candidates
now there are systemic issues to solve
as well so you've got the trumpists on
one hand
you've got the problems of the
democratic party gerrymandering and the
fact that republicans live more rurally
and democrats live more in urban areas
that's a structural disadvantage to the
left i've talked about it before
the senate is fundamentally undemocratic
california has almost 40 million people
they get two senators
wyoming has 550 000 people they get two
senators that's a structural
disadvantage i think during impeachment
we we calculated something like the
senators representing 17 percent of the
population
had enough votes in the senate to acquit
trump yes
the electoral college is a structural
disadvantage a republican president has
only won the popular vote once
in the last um i think it's the last 20
years right i mean
bush lost the popular vote in 2000 but
got elected
bush won the popular vote in 2004. i
think that's the one republican that's
actually
won the popular vote for president in
the last 20 years
now lots of people see the whole thing i
just laid out
and they claim to have the solution and
this is actually a virus that's going
around not the pan not not the
coronavirus
but the virus of thinking that you have
a simple answer
because it works well in a tweet or
whatever like it's really popular now on
twitter
to say stupid democrats think they need
to move to the center but really they
need to move to the left if they move
left they win
you'll see tweets like every democrat
who ran on medicare for all one
just go way way left and every democrat
wins democrats take over
there is huge self-selection bias there
the democrats who ran on medicare for
all
were mostly in districts where they
would win regardless of their position
on health care because of the dynamics
of the district
other democrats say we need to start
winning morality messaging
and show that our policies are really
the moral majority policies well
that matters to some voters in some
places the point is
anyone who's coming to you on twitter
reddit youtube cnn
with a simple answer this is the one
thing
they are trying to simplify something
that is really complicated i have no
interest in doing that and i'm not even
pretending to have the answers today
i'm laying out the stakes and the
conversation so
you know if you want to have fun and
make fun of dumb trumpets there's no
shortage of that
and it's satisfying and it's
entertaining and
we participate in it to some degree but
it's not going to help us win
let's not imagine that it will help us
win 10 and 20 years from now making fun
of the trumpists won't give us the
returns on policy that we want
that's how i'm thinking about it i want
to hear from you
and hear your ideas and we're going to
continue talking about this during the
transition
phase so just everything is going wrong
for donald trump i think you're going to
like this one
we talked yesterday about the great
developments in terms of the coronavirus
vaccine the vaccine being developed by
pfizer
was announced yesterday to have a 90
effectiveness in a large
clinical trial has not yet been peer
reviewed but it looks
very good donald trump immediately tried
to attach his name to it immediately
tweeting in all caps
stock market up big vaccine coming soon
report 90 effective such great news
vice president mike pence also weighed
in and he just straight up tried to take
credit for it
he tweeted huge news thanks to the
public
private partnership forged by trump
pfizer
announced its coronavirus vaccine trial
is effective
preventing infection in 90 percent of
its volunteers
this is all made up and in fact it's
such nonsense that
pfizer's head of vaccine research
immediately clarified we took no
money from trump's so-called operation
warp speed
katherine janssen head of vaccine
research at pfizer told the new york
times
we have never taken any money from the
u.s government she also told the new
york times that pfizer
was never part of operation warp speed
it's actually hilarious
that trump and pence are trying to
crowbar their way
into this and as reported by bloomberg
quote
among the front runners theirs is the
only vaccine project
that did not take funding from the white
house led operation warp speed program
to bolster research development or
manufacturing
you like almost start to feel just the
tiniest bit sorry for these people
but we actually don't because they keep
insisting
they won uh but but biden did fraud and
all this different stuff
no that's not true okay but now they say
we got
we got the vaccine done because we gave
pfizer money well no
pfizer didn't take any money from you
okay well something
something and they get nothing there's
actually
even more hilarity to this which is that
this is really a german vaccine
work on this vaccine started in germany
in january
because the ceo of bioentech which is
the
partner company with pfizer that
developed the vaccine
the ceo of bioentech read about the
virus in the lancet
and realized this is going to be huge so
they immediately started working on the
vaccine meanwhile trump in january was
saying oh we've got this completely
under control
it's one person from china it's going to
be fine trump's saying in was it march
15 cases or maybe even april 15 cases
will soon be zero
that's why this vaccine is now almost
ready because in germany when trump was
doing nothing
they started working on it donald trump
and mike pence
are trying to take credit for a vaccine
but it was actually a vaccine
developed in germany by a german company
founded by turkish immigrants
produced in the u.s by a company that
took
no money from donald trump's operation
warp speed
that's the truth don't let the door hit
you on the way out guys
we'll have continued coverage of the
vaccine make sure you're following me on
twitter
where you can find me at d pacman the
david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that
i have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that you can get 70 off a david
pakman show membership using the coupon
code
fresh start why because we're taking a
fresh start here it's a new beginning
uh use that coupon code freshstart all
one word all lowercase
to discount the membership of your
choice at joinpakman.com
i have something completely shocking to
report to you
uh president-elect joe biden has
announced his coronavirus task force
there's not a single member of his
family on it none of joe biden's family
is on the task force
not a single pillow salesman is on the
task force
there's no faith healers on the task
force it's just doctors
the task force includes seven doctors
david kessler a pediatrician
a former surgeon general um dr
marcela nunez smith who's a professor of
epidemiology at yale dr rick bright an
immunologist and vaccine researcher who
refused to do trump's propaganda bidding
dr zeke emanuel who's a bioethicist dr
atul gawande
surgeon and public health expert dr
michael osterholm
another epidemiologist i actually have
an atul gawande story atul gawande wrote
this great book the checklist manifesto
and when i had my appendectomy um 2 a.m
in the morning this was like a year ago
surgeon comes in dr matthew nays uh says
hey here's who i am here's the office i
work in and his specialty was
i think it was like endocrinology
surgery it just sounded a lot like what
i know
dr atul gawande's specialty is i'm all
zoned out in the middle you know i'm on
drugs appendectomy
all this stuff and i say do you know
atul gawande and he says i do
it's my office mate or whatever
and at that point i at least hoped i was
in good hands i was very drugged up it
was easy to convince me that i was and
it worked out great but anyway dr
atul gawande really good guy great
inclusion
but a group of just doctors with
relevant specializations
and a picture of their first meeting was
released joe biden
yes joe biden already has held his first
coronavirus task force meeting
he's still months out from being
president joe biden just sat there
taking notes you see
if you're looking at the picture of the
meeting there was no tv on in the back
of the room
so if joe biden got bored he could watch
fox news or something
so obviously i'm being sort of jokey but
this is very serious this is a real
change in the trajectory of the us
dealing with coronavirus in that the
president will deal with it and will
deal with it with relevant doctors
no media figures no radiologists saying
let's go for herd immunity
no tv anchors no nonsense and the one
little flavor i like
is that the inclusion of rick bright in
this group of doctors
is very likely to heavily trigger donald
trump you might remember dr rick bright
was a trump whistleblower who came out
and said they're pushing me
to start saying things about
hydroxychloroquine that are not based in
fact and of course
rick bright was correct nobody talks
about hydroxychloroquine anymore he was
one of the
few people doing good work at the time
and
uh he blew the whistle and his inclusion
here
is very likely to trigger donald trump
now there was a question
why no fouchy where is dr fauci why is
dr fauci not part of this
my assumption is that joe biden
understands
dr fauci is running nih
he is a you know loosely speaking an
administration
employee and it would not really be
appropriate
to include him in this group right now
i'm
sure that if donald trump fires dr fauci
or uh when dr when when joe biden is
inaugurated
dr fauci is going to be a part of this
there is no question whatsoever
i don't think fauci is sitting there you
know rigging is
ringing his hands wondering if he will
be useful to the incoming administration
i'm sure he knows that he will be and i
think joe biden is probably
probably doing the appropriate thing by
not yet including him but
we're already off to you know this is
going to be a long fight
and we're going to need to wear masks
for for some time and things are not
going to be normal for some time but
this is a start that certainly inspires
some confidence uh you guys have to see
this
for a very brief period of time it
started to maybe look like donald trump
would consider conceding to joe biden
accepting that he lost to joe biden we
heard that melania
and jared kushner were supposedly
telling donald trump you might want to
look at conceding
this seems to have done a 180 yesterday
with some
absurd triggered tweets from donald
trump
claiming that he won essentially all of
the key battleground states
for this election trump also sent out
his press secretary kaylee mckennany
as well as rnc chair ronald mcdaniel
plus a lawyer
to some room in a hotel to claim that
the fight will continue for a long time
we'll talk about that a little bit later
it's starting to be beyond belief that
this is even happening but take a look
at these tweets trump first tweeting
about nevada
saying nevada is turning out to be a
cesspool
of fake votes uh m
schlapp and adam laxalt are finding
things that when released will be
absolutely shocking now that tweet was
flagged
as misinformation by twitter joe biden
is currently winning in nevada
by 36 000 votes that's about 3
it's not even in recount territory in
nevada
trump then goes on to wisconsin trump
tweeting quote wisconsin is looking very
good
needs a little time statutorily will
happen
soon trump claiming i guess that he's
going to win wisconsin now
the margin in wisconsin is about 20 000
votes
this is the same margin by which donald
trump won in 2016.
he didn't complain then but now he's
complaining
then donald trump goes on to
pennsylvania tweeting quote pennsylvania
prevented us from watching much of the
ballot count
unthinkable and illegal in this country
now twitter also flagged that as
disinformation
the lead in pennsylvania for joe biden
has grown to 45 000 votes
and both republican and democratic poll
watchers
were allowed to oversee trump is lying
and then trump going on to georgia
saying quote georgia will be a
big presidential win as it was the night
of the election now as of this
moment georgia has not been called but
biden's lead
there has grown to 12 000 votes now as i
said earlier on in the program
there's no doubt that these are thin
margins in some states
mostly still larger margins than trump
had in 2016
but this is delusional and
completely humiliating at this point
donald trump
claiming he's going to win states he
didn't win
when how what what and if you actually
ask
as we saw in the press conference
yesterday with kaylee mckennany if you
actually say
do you have proof of specific
fraudulent or illegal votes the answer
is not
yes they go off into well we weren't
given access
and well then why are you suspecting
that that happened
well we just need to let the courts play
well but why do courts need to be
involved if you don't actually have
evidence yet a lot of that came up
during this gong show press conference
with kaylee mckennany which was so
pathetic and lie riddled that even fox
news had to cut away
let's discuss that next and then later
we'll get we'll get into the
growing fury that the current president
the last gasp president has with fox
news
so yesterday afternoon comes on the east
coast
very abruptly scheduled press conference
was scheduled
with donald trump's press secretary
kelly mckenney
rnc chair a woman ronna mcdaniel and
some lawyer
now you might ask is it appropriate for
the white house press secretary to be
doing this
fear not kaylee mckenney opened the
press conference by saying
i'm kaylee mckennany and i'm here in my
personal capacity she's not there as
white house press secretary
which just continues to be completely
hilarious but
there's just too much going on to even
focus on that
so kaylee is asked during this press
conference
do you have evidence of even a single
illegal vote being cast
and she doesn't she says a lot of stuff
but she doesn't take a look
sounds like do you know that brunch
votes were actually asked or are you
simply saying
we don't know because we couldn't see
you look uh what we are asking for here
is patience ron i just mentioned to you
the more than i believe it was 130
affidavits in michigan alone
we're aware of all the reports of
thousands of votes in nevada that were
cast by those who are not eligible we're
hearing
these reports we're seeing them come in
we are vetting them
we are getting affidavits so right now
we would point you to all of that that
information is publicly available but
what we're asking for right now
is patience as we explore these equal
protection claims among others
so as you can see the answer to do you
have evidence of a single illegal or
fraudulent vote for now is no they don't
actually have evidence of that but then
this is just the great part
this aired during a fox news's neil
cavuto
show cavuto actually interrupts this
nonsense and says whoa whoa whoa
we can't air this these are very serious
allegations that are completely unproven
and what
i'm not going to defend fox news or neil
cavuto in any general sense
but what i like about this clip we're
going to see is that neil cavuto is
putting a name to the fact that
these are outrageous allegations these
are allegations that call into question
at the most basic level whether voting
even works in this country
and neil cavuto points out hey you know
we can't normalize these claims when
trump comes out and says it was all
stolen
and i'm going to get georgia and i'm
going to get wisconsin and he said
nevada and pennsylvania
these are wildly serious allegations
that are unproven and
we can't air it is what neil cavuto said
illegal votes
i just think we have to be very clear
she's charging the other side is
welcoming fraud and welcoming illegal
voting unless she has more details to
back that up
i can't in good countenance continue
showing you this i want to make sure
that maybe they do have something to
back that up
but that's an explosive charge to make
the other side is effectively
rigging and cheating uh if she does
bring proof of that of course we'll take
you back
so far she has started saying right at
the outset welcoming fraud welcoming
illegal voting not so fast
a little more after this so this really
is amazing and to be clear
you know this is not that fox news is
great or trustworthy
fox news is insanely untrustworthy uh
even some of their anchors though are
saying
we can't air this in good conscience at
night
during prime time when you get to
hannity
and tucker and laura ingram i don't know
about janine pirro she might be
suspended right now
they are going full bore into it was
stolen
but at least here neil cavuto says no
dice
and hilariously all sorts of fox viewers
started
immediately tweeting neil cavuto must be
fired because he did this
so let's not think for a second that fox
news is now respectable
they're still allowing hannity and
carlson and ingram to do their
screeching screeds every single night
but what's great about this is that it
has completely triggered the trumpian
right
and this will lead into the story we'll
do after my conversation today with
peter joseph which is that
trump now is furious with fox news
and he has been relegated to tweeting
clips
of newsmax if you can imagine he's mad
at fox
he needs to be there's got to be
somebody that continues to say that it's
all been stolen even during the
so-called
news portions and he found it at newsmax
we'll look at clips of that later on
make sure you're following the show on
instagram at davidpakmanshow
follow me on instagram at david.pakman
for evidence we've gotten some really
strong retweets lately
from some really great people a colin
hanks the son of tom hanks
is now following the show and has been
amplifying
some of our material uh superstar
actress gabrielle union retweeting some
of our stuff
really really great and we appreciate it
so much follow me at david.pacman on
instagram to see some of that we'll take
a quick break and be back after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show
as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpacman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
welcome back to the david pakman show
all right welcome back to the program we
sadly and tragically had a
guest no call no show on us last minute
but it's a great opportunity since we
missed live calls last week because of
the election and the craziness
to hear from a few folks through the
discord at davidpakman.com
discord let's uh first go
to laura from richmond laura from
richmond
you were on uh what's on your mind today
laura
oh boy hold on one second laura we have
uh we don't have things properly
uh cued in i can hear you but just bear
with me just
just one moment and we're gonna be your
your audio is coming out of a very very
strange place
and we need it coming out of a normal
place okay laura you were i can now hear
you in the right spot
awesome uh well today's my birthday
happy birthday
thank you um i just wanted to say that
um
i watched your live stream of the vice
presidential
debate and also um
kamala and biden's acceptance speeches
and it was
it was a great experience thank you
thank you for doing that for us
thank you for watching it um so
my question today revolves around the
25th amendment
right i haven't really heard a lot about
that lately
but it seems like the more trump seems
to be getting
unhinged yeah would it be something that
would be
uh the proper thing to do
for the vice president who i haven't
heard a thing from
by the way well he went on vacation this
week pence went on vacation to florida
this week
no i mean you bring up a good question
so there's two questions would it be
appropriate to remove trump via the 25th
amendment of course it would and it
would have been appropriate years ago
is it going to happen in the last nine
weeks or however many weeks
he has of his presidency it's not
because it depends on his cabinet and
the vice president and they're they're
not going to do it so
yes it would be appropriate no it's not
going to happen
it just seems like i'm i'm afraid that
he's going to intentionally
do something that harms this country
that will be very difficult to recover
from
that's completely wrong already yeah
that's completely plausible but um you
know
in being hyper realist trump's cabinet's
not removing him you know laura that's
the reality and we have to deal with
uh the cards were dealt as they say yeah
they paid for their positions
in a sense they did and they are not
going to remove this guy but
listen it's it's down to weeks you know
i guess that's what we have try to
limit damage during the next few weeks
well we've held on this long i think we
can hold on a little bit longer
let's hope so that's my hope that's
exactly my hope but thank you so much
for taking my call
my pleasure laura from richmond great to
hear from you
uh let's go next to leon from boston via
discord leon you're on the air
hi david what's up how you doing um
surviving how are you doing good good
my my question is this at this point
i do realize that we have to go through
all these lawsuits and uh
this healthcare lawsuit and everything
that's trump's doing yeah but i somehow
somehow feel it's like giving him more
fuel we keep talking and talking about
him and talking about him and all his
lawsuits and everything i understand we
have to do it
but it's just like he will he ever act
just go away
even and even when he's not present
anymore he won't just go away
it's just like i i'm just i'm just sick
of him basically you know what i mean i
totally get it
you're fatigued we're all fatigued from
him i mean we all have to understand
that there's two ways this could go and
we don't really have control over it one
is
at a certain point trump could leave the
white house for thanksgiving and never
come back and then he just won't be
president
michael cohen said trump might leave the
white house for christmas and then just
never return and then
he'll go away and we might never hear
from him again
or he might launch a channel
after joe biden is president and
continue to be a presence and try to run
almost like a parallel presidency
for four years i i just have no idea and
unfortunately
we can't control it either it could
really go either way and we may be
dealing with trump's voice for a while
oh he also said he's gonna run for
president in 2024 i mean i know
i'm gonna i'm gonna talk about that on
on the friday show
i think we shouldn't even worry about
that yet this guy doesn't even get a
hint
we don't want you that's it go away but
what you have to remember and i
addressed this
on today's show is 71 million people
voted for the guy
and these were thin margins in four
states
by which he lost so a ton of people do
want the guy that's what's crazy um
i i think people are just you know what
i think it is i think it comes down to
that one woman in florida
before he when he was when they asked
her if she wanted to wear masks
why she won't wear masks she said the
reason i don't wear a mask is because i
don't wear
pants either i'll say pants i won't say
the actual words that she said but
yeah okay yes i remember her it's just
crazy that's the kind of people you're
dealing with and that's the kind of
people that vote for trump
that's true but but unless we get some
of them to see reason
or to stay home quite frankly the left
won't make big progress and that's why
i you know i addressed the commentary
today about this leon i appreciate it
what part of boston are you from
uh cambridge cambridge okay so not even
really boston
no no that's okay we include you guys
yeah i know you went to boston bu but
thank you for taking my call
all right thank you very much um wait i
went to bu no i never went to
i taught at bc maybe leon meant he went
to bu i'm not even sure about that
just a little bit of confusion to an
otherwise perfect
perfect perfect phone call we are taking
calls
via discord at davidpakman.com discord
let's go to sarah and i believe it's
hamburg germany is that right sarah
hi yes it is in germany most yeah hi
how are you i believe that there's some
cities of hamburg in the u.s which is
why i asked
yeah there's one in new york at least
at least one exactly what's on your mind
yeah
i was wondering i heard that
um december 14th there's going to be
another
vote for the electoral college well let
me explain that sarah that's great that
you're asking this so
you know there's all this talk about the
media doesn't get to call
an election but that's right this is the
situation every year
states have a certain amount of time to
certify the election
and then this year it's december 14th
that the electors actually
vote and that's when the election
becomes official
that's the case every year and that is
absolutely true
okay um so are they required because
i'm hearing that they're not actually
required to
go with the popular vote of their state
and they could just vote technically
however they want so technically let's
say they could vote for
trump that is absolutely true this is
something called a faithless elector and
the reason that this was
something that is allowed
constitutionally
is so that ultimately electors have the
opportunity to correct
imagine that a total madman were elected
like donald trump in 2016.
electors could have said we have to
exercise judgment and not
cast our ballot in this way and sarah if
you just put me on speaker make sure to
take us off because we're starting to
get feedback of my own voice
um and and in 2016 in fact two electors
were faithless donald trump won 306
electoral votes but only 304
actually went with him so that could
happen never in history
has it reversed the results of an
election and if joe biden has
290 or 306 electoral votes i'm confident
that there will not be enough faithless
electors
to uh turn the election results to trump
right just you i mean i understand being
faithful but just to confirm this is a
possibility
it is it is technically it is always a
possibility in every election yes
i mean what wow okay what do you think
happens then
let's say that happens just
hypothetically i'm not saying that would
but what happens what happens
i i don't know i don't know if there's
any recourse um
and uh so i i mean it's a great question
i don't know the answer to that
all right well i guess we'll just have
to see
yes we will i don't yeah i don't again i
don't it's not going to happen there's
not
you know trump would need 20 faithless
electors
or 36 if uh joe biden wins georgia
that's not going to happen all right
well let's hope for the best
let's all right uh sarah thank you very
much great to have
calls from our friends in uh in germany
let's go next to uh
wait hold on i wanted to go to herschel
in denver herschel in denver you're on
the air
hey david how's it going good how are
you i'm doing pretty good
okay thanks for uh answering my call uh
i i just had a i think it's been so
unhealthy just talking about trump all
the time
and i was really interested to know as
uh as progressives
are there some house representatives
that were elected to that or that were
elected that we should be really excited
about
yeah jamal bowman is interesting uh
corey bush i mean there's there's quite
a list and we're going to be reviewing
it but
you know i think that in the the house
is a mixed bag
because so far democrats actually lost
seats but there were some interesting
wins
as well so there's a lot to go over and
we'll do a full breakdown of the house
soon
great i really appreciate your
commentary on election night
i feel like i was a voice of reason for
my family i just kept telling
hey just just wait it out wait till the
morning i really appreciate that and
just out of curiosity are you stacking
bricks
am i standing bricks yeah are you doing
some kind of construction
no i was just i was just banging on my
workstation here oh okay very good it's
kind of like when trump slams the
lectern
that's right it's same idea very good i
really drive my points over
i like it well now points points taken
all right my friend i appreciate the
call
thank you great to hear from folks uh
all over really all over and we could go
you should see
there's countries here donald trump
hasn't even heard of that we could go to
let me go next to christina from texas
christina from texas you're on the air
oh
can you hear me yes i can wow oh my gosh
how exciting
um well uh as you know texas
and being from houston is really big in
oil and gas
and being a progressive working in oil
and gas
is definitely um tough especially with
this
these times right now everyone's really
vocal
about their opinions and now kind of
like the previous color it feels like
unhealthy to keep hearing it
and talking about it so i was wondering
how you would go about it
especially if maybe your co-workers
enjoy
talking about that stuff and how you
would
deal with it i guess i mean i would
probably
take a very light touch and just not
participate in the conversations are
people deliberately pulling you into
political conversations you don't want
to have
yeah i feel like definitely like my boss
will come and talk about it
and you know it feels like
i need to stand up because you know it's
very ignorant comments
and i feel like so it sounds almost like
you're
you're mixed because on the one hand you
don't even want to be talking about
politics but on the other hand when you
hear
ridiculous nonsense you don't feel great
about just
allowing it to get by unchallenged
correct
that is tough i don't know i don't know
what i would do in that case i mean i
think
if you wanted to simultaneously make a
point that you disagree but not really
engage you could say
hey you know what um i i don't agree at
all with you on that
and millions of people don't but i just
don't even really want to engage because
i
i want to get my work done and i don't
know i mean that would be tough
particularly if it's your boss i don't
know that i have good advice
well actually that's really helpful i
think i'll try that thank you
all right well let me know how it works
yes thanks
all right great to hear from you there
was uh kristen from houston
uh very very exciting stuff let's go
next to oh this is interesting let's go
to rasmus from estonia
i've been to estonia it is a magical
place rasmus
you were on are you calling from tallinn
or elsewhere hello
hello can you hear me yes i can
yes good to uh good to hear you
i thought i have been following you for
uh a month i think
nothing but i enjoyed all your shows and
everything thank you well i enjoy i
enjoy the country of estonia
yes are you calling from tallinn
uh no i am calling from tartu okay
that's still allowed
yeah what's on your mind
there are a few things that i wanted to
ask you
one of them is about
some of these uh some of these
republicans that
gets re-elected and re-elected despite
being uh so
bad at their job like mitch mcconnell
what is behind this like how can they
keep getting re-elected over and over
it's because the state of kentucky is a
very
red state and even with a bad
candidate you have a population in
kentucky a portion of the population
will never vote for democrats and so you
put
a republican on the ticket and they
recognize the name
mitch mcconnell they say i'm a
republican
mitch mcconnell is a republican i vote
for mitch mcconnell
it's really that simple unfortunately
rasmus
yeah so no matter what they do how much
they fail
because of the party they will choose
and to be to be fair a lot of those
republicans don't think mitch mcconnell
have failed they think he's succeeded
because he's gotten so many judges
confirmed he blocked merrick garland
from the supreme court in 2016. i mean
it's not some people don't care that he
failed others believe he has succeeded
and
and really in some sense uh some sense
he has rasmus i know you had more
questions but i am
out of time for today so i hope to hear
from you again
from the beautiful country of estonia
glad we were able to take a few calls
because of a last minute cancellation we
will take calls again guys and i know
many people didn't get on
that's just the reality we all have to
contend with all right and we will take
a quick break
and be back very soon the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about them
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so this really has to be seen to be
believed donald trump and trumpists are
now increasingly furious with fox news
i guess because fox admits that joe
biden won
for example and a fox news also cut away
from a press conference yesterday
with trump's press secretary kelly
mckennany because she was lying and
neil cavuto said whoa whoa whoa she if
she presents some evidence for these
claims we'll go back to it but these are
really serious allegations
to be making about voter fraud so the
point is trump now
and many trumpists um are furious with
fox news and
trump has doubled down and humiliated
himself even more if you can imagine
by starting to tweet out clips of
newsmax now
if you haven't heard of newsmax good for
you first of all
newsmax is sort of similar to oan in
some
way it's like a low low-budget version
of fox news some people say it looks
kind of like a porn parody of fox news
they have massive integrity issues they
emailed their subscriber list during the
pandemic
saying the worst thing you could do is
get a vaccine
because vaccines are one of the biggest
scams among the american people so you
sort of get the idea of where
a news max is trump now i guess because
he's
furious with fox news regularly is
tweeting out newsmax clips
and you have to see it to believe it
they've set up interviews
where it's not even clear that the
anchor understands the questions
they almost look like infomercials where
the anchor is sort of like uh
tell me all the ways in which this was
stolen from donald trump and then they
just give some mouthpiece
on you know uninterrupted time to just
say
tell lies here's one with an rnc spoke
spokesperson on fraud claims what can we
expect to see in court
we will pursue every legal avenue
because what's going on right now
is a total travesty this is not the
united states of america where we have
free and fair elections with legal votes
cast and that's what who decides
elections not media organizations
now i i'm not going to play long clips
there's a lot more to this but my
suspicion
is that exposure to too much of this
drivel
probably is bad for your health i don't
want to do that to the audience so i'm
going to keep the clips pretty short
here's another one with um actually this
is with congressman jody heiss
i'll talk to you about jody heiss in a
moment but
this was around the time trump tweeted
he's going to win georgia
yesterday i don't mean on election day
yesterday trump tweeted he's going to
win georgia
and here is congressman jody heiss
claiming the same thing
because of either reporting or recording
or who even knows what take a look
it's very close and quite frankly i
believe it's on the verge of getting a
lot
closer fulton county just came out just
within the last hour or so
recognizing that they have a significant
issue
on reporting that they did on friday
wxia the nbc television affiliate
is already saying that this is
significantly going to
change the count in favor of president
trump
at the same time gwinnett county has
come out in the last hour or so
indicating that they likewise have some
glitches
now that congressman there jody heiss
he's a disgusting guy
back in uh it was 2014
he claimed that there was a gay plot
to sodomize your children and also
in 2014 said his belief is that women
need their husband's permission to enter
politics
that's jody heiss who was interviewed on
newsmax
and then signal boosted by donald trump
and then here is trump flunky richard
grinnell you might remember richard
grenell
from the rnc he actually spoke at the
rnc
just claiming it's all fraud like it
just
the entire thing is fraudulent every
single one of these videos i've played
for you so far has been flagged by
twitter
as disinformation about an election take
a look
that are now coming back to haunt us
ballots that were mailed out of state
people um saying i haven't lived in
nevada for years
we saw more than 3 000 people who
lived out of state get ballots we've
we've brought those to the authorities
uh
attention many of those people have
broken the residency requirements
um this is just the tip of the iceberg
so whatever the outcome of the election
is when it's certified and it is not
certified yet and we still have
um tens of thousands of votes yet to be
counted
just absolute complete
and total nonsense and it really
like it's almost getting sad in more
ways than we imagined
and if you are the president and all you
have left
is newsmax clips to try
to make it look like there are people
who agree with you
just pack it up go and play golf the
rest of your term
joe biden has already launched a
coronavirus task force
just announce your turning over
management of the virus to joe biden the
incoming the elect
administration just go and um i believe
it was trump's former personal attorney
michael cohen who said yesterday in an
interview
he expects that at christmas time trump
will leave and go
to you know his resort in florida or
somewhere
and that he won't even come back to the
white house i think that's possible
trump actually doing things as president
may be over as we know it there's
nothing on his schedule there hasn't
been anything on his schedule
on any day since the election this may
change
but trump really may just be done and he
will just tweet about how he really won
and then quietly disappear around
christmas time we don't yet know
but it's getting really really
embarrassing unless
unless unless and this is very important
unless trump restarts his maga rallies
and there is a report claiming he plans
to do that
and i want to talk about that now there
is a
a hilarious report from axios now it's
not actually comedy
it's it's serious but it's hilarious in
what it's suggesting
and the axios report claims that donald
trump is actually getting ready
to restart those depraved he calls them
maga rallies i call them corona rallies
and it's all to keep the fight going
against supposed voter fraud that he
claims
allow joe biden to steal the election
from him as of right now
these are all baseless claims without
any evidence
so the plan as per axios is that the
trump team
will announce recounts in specific
states
and then they will hold rallies in those
states and the idea will be to fly
in and really raise money for the
recounts which are expensive
and also try to kind of build public
support for those recounts and the idea
that these states were fraudulently
stolen from donald trump now as i told
you yesterday
in the story about trump's last scam if
you look at the fine print of the
fundraising that donald trump is doing i
know that if you watched yesterday's
show you know this but i want to repeat
it
if you look at the fine print of trump's
fundraising for so-called recounts and
fighting fraud
the fine print is fifty percent of of
every dollar you donate not you but the
people who would be dumb enough to do it
fifty percent of every dollar donated
goes not to fund the recounts whoa sorry
i hit my mic they're getting a little
too excited
but half the money goes to paying off
donald trump's campaign debt
so it's sort of like the final scam on
the tail end
of what has been four years of a scam
presidency
and the key states that they're looking
at are reportedly georgia arizona and
pennsylvania
now there have been reports that team
trump is not all on the same page about
this like for example
we got a report two days ago that rudy
giuliani
wants trump to do rallies but that
trump's
chief of staff mark meadows and
son-in-law jared kushner
want trump to concede but then there was
a conflicting report that jared kushner
actually wants trump to do rallies and
mark meadows said something like
consent concession isn't even in our
vocabulary
we'll eventually know the truth
according to this axios report
everybody's on the same page and they
plan to get trump reelected who the hell
knows
but if trump does do these rallies it
would not only be a scam
but it would be extra irresponsible
given coronavirus you're not even
running for anything at this point like
we know that the rallies have been
responsible for hundreds and likely even
thousands of deaths
while trump was running a campaign
at least he could say i have to win
for the good of the country i believe
him winning would have been bad
and we know because joe biden did it
that you can campaign safely
but at least he had something he was
running for this is now
really just bottom of the barrel trash
like this is how you destroy a country
he's not only refusing to concede which
is not a legal issue concession is
merely a formality
but it makes him look foolish and it's
bad for the country
but he's reportedly going to try to
re-litigate the election
through campaign-style rallies the likes
of which were already irresponsible due
to the pandemic before the election
now if you look at the court judgment so
far
to figure out does he have a shot here
the court judgments so far
about voter fraud have gone universally
against trump's campaign
all of them saying there's nothing here
to move forward on there's just there's
no there there
but this now these rallies would be to
get to the court of public opinion
get crowds of people where the focus is
no longer
vote for me on election day the focus is
we need money to beat joe biden with
lawsuits
so if the reports were true that jared
kushner and melania were telling trump
to concede
it seems that those efforts have failed
and we also shouldn't understate the
impact of these possible rallies on
trump's ego which at the end of the day
that's really a huge role in what trump
decides to do
each day and a big piece of doing these
rallies would be ego and nothing else
will republican senators even speak up
and call trump out if he does this or
are they going to remain quiet because
understand that as of just a few hours
ago
only four republican senators have even
acknowledged that joe biden won
and that donald trump lost those are
most recently susan collins
and we had mitt romney say biden won we
had lisa murkowski say it we had been
sass
say it it is absolutely pathetic and
we're going to follow
whether these rallies become a reality
and whether someone is able to talk
donald trump out of it because
ultimately that's what this may come
down to
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192davidp
one of our viewers is very worried take
a listen to this hey
david pac-man it's thomas
from austin right hey man
i have to really tell you
i am a gay man okay and
i have noticed that your
complexion is starting
to turn very white i don't know if it's
the election
and you're staying inside and doing your
research
but man get your vitamin d
because we have to see a
sexy young progressive
tan whatever you call
yourself awesome nazi jewish whatever
we have to have that in our progressive
fields um so yeah man
looking a little pale in my opinion
okay i appreciate the kids
can you believe this is my job um i
appreciate the concern
i am uh making it a a a point
of spending time outside every single
day it's been unseasonably warm lately
i've been biking i've been running i had
my vitamin d
checked and it's looking pretty strong
uh that was um
right at the end of winter i did that
and
if at the end of winter my d was okay
you would think my
vitamin d level would would be okay now
but i'm going to keep on it i appreciate
the concern we've got a great bonus show
for you today
we are going to talk about where do the
what are what we are calling trumpus
dead enders on the election where are
they going now
what media are they consuming we will
talk about donald trump's firing of a
secretary of defense
and we will talk about vladimir putin's
hesitation to congratulate joseph r
biden jr all of those stories
and more on the bonus show get instant
access to the bonus show by becoming a
member
at joinpakman.com if you want a massive
discount use the coupon code fresh start
that coupon code will save you an
ungodly amount off of membership when
you sign up
i'll see you on the bonus show
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's
sponsor is blinkist the app that lets
you read or listen
to an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist for free
and save 25 off of a subscription
when you go to blinkist dot com slash
david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video